anybody who's interested in symbolism
will at one point face the question of
the occult and things like Freemasonry
and all these secret organizations and a
vision of symbolism which is related to
that sphere and so in this video I'm
going to look at the the question of the
occult and certain types of symbolism
magic the Freemasonry and all that stuff
we'll try to look at it objectively as
possible and I have to warn you as we
start this is probably going to be
something of a rant so hopefully you can
that'll be ok
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
don't before I begin the video there are
few things I wanted to talk about first
of all I put out a video last week it
was a an interpretation of the latest
Spider Man into the spider-verse
movie somehow for some reason that the
the notifications did not go out and so
if you miss that video you should check
it out yeah it's a lot of fun I did it
again with Thomas from the storytellers
channel so you should enjoy that um sure
you will enjoy that there's also quite a
few things coming in the next few months
I will be in Seattle in May and we're
doing a big conference with father
Stephen Freeman and other speakers and
so if you're on the west coast I would
love to meet you
so please I put the I'll put the link
down below in the description please you
know get your ticket and hopefully I'll
see you there there are also my icon
carving workshops which are coming soon
one in June on the east on the near in
Connecticut near Boston and another one
in South Carolina in September
those fill up are filling up so if you
want to come spend the week with me to
carve and to talk about symbolism please
go ahead and sign up for that so on with
the video now as I grew up in a certain
culture we'll call it an evangelical
conservative evangelical culture I faced
something that was called chick comics
and I don't know if any of you have
heard of chick comics in chick comics
you had a this very anti-catholic strain
and what they would do in chick comics
is they would show certain aspects of
the Catholic liturgy for example and
then they would show how evil the
liturgy is because it has these occult
and ancient Egyptian or pagan influences
and so I remember for example in the
Catholic Church they have liturgical
fans which we got which we also have in
the Orthodox Church and then they would
show how these liturgical fans are the
same as the liturgical fans that were
used in Egypt therefore proving that the
Catholic Church is evil and satanic and
so I as I grew up with that stuff like I
said I think I said this before this
stuff didn't come from my family it came
from let's say the surrounding
culture in which I was bathing um and so
growing up as I discovered symbolism and
as I discovered symbolic structures and
imagistic thinking liturgy ritual all of
this stuff as I discovered this of
course I started to look back at all
this silly nonsense that people were
saying with something of righteous anger
you could call it and what annoys me at
this particular moment is to find the
exact same attitude inside some strands
of Orthodoxy where the same attitude is
applied what we're seeing is the
reduction of symbolism to their
historical contingency that is somehow
by pointing to the historical origin of
an image or or they or the one that you
can find or finding some analogy visual
analogy between something which exists
today and something which existed in the
past we somehow that's enough to explain
the symbolism first of all what that is
is an extremely simple minded vision of
symbolism and second of all it is a way
in which to just simply show our our
somewhat our superiority in being able
to identify the analogies between
different cultures and then to decry
them as being evil and our own version
of Christianity to be this amazing pure
thing and the reason why it frustrates
me is that as you learn start to
understand symbolism and understand the
structures then you start to see that
that's not enough to understand
symbolism simply pointing to the analogy
between one symbolic image and another
is not enough to explain it now the
reason why I'm getting kind of pumped up
about this right now is because there
are a bunch of people that have been
attacking Jordan Peterson from the
Christian camp and I understand the
criticism against Jordan Peter said I
have said in many videos that there are
plenty of things that we can say to
criticize Jordan Peterson in fact I
finished reading Vox day's book and I
believe that I could write a much better
criticism of Jordan Peterson which would
much more accurate and also would cut in
the right places instead of strange
conspiracy occult directions now what do
I mean okay I want to give you a few
examples of this the the the main
example that I want to bring up is some
there's a guy I won't name him because I
don't want to get into polemics who is
pointing out how occult Jorn Peterson is
and the way he's doing it is exactly the
way I said he is showing something that
Jordan Peterson is show is talking about
and then he's using words like this is
the same as the occult this is the same
as Kabbalah
and when you hear those words this is a
cult this is Kabbalah this is a magical
this is from you know the magical
thinking when you hear that you should
be very suspicious because it's a way to
simply discount something without
actually looking at it and so you know
the word Kabbalah for example do you
know what that means it just means
tradition that's what tradition means
come there the word occult what does the
word occult me the word occult means
secret it's the same word
it's a synonym to the word for example
mystery and it's then it's also a
synonym to the word sacrament and so the
sacraments the mysteries of the church
are the secret teachings of the church
and if you read in the Church Fathers
you will find texts which are called
mystic mist agachi and this mystic ID is
the secret explanation of an outer form
that that appears in the Christian
Church the the ancient Christian Church
had a mystic mist agha jiggle structure
it had an initiatory structure which is
that if you are not initiated into the
mysteries into the sacraments of the
Church then you were not given certain
aspects of the mystery even today in the
Orthodox Church we have a moment during
the liturgy where we say all the
catechumen must leave that is all those
that are not initiated into the
Christian community must leave at this
point because what is after that is part
of the sacramentality of the church it
is the mystery of the church in which we
come together and we we participate in
the the the act of communion together
and the act of communion is not without
its it doesn't if you look at it
objectively it looks very strange we are
eating the blood and body of the
Incarnate logos and so the only reason
why we don't think that strange is
because it is our culture and it is our
own initiative practice and so if we if
we look at an image and we see how weird
it is people that's I see it all the
time people will look at images and look
at how weird this is
look at how strange that says and
somehow because it looks weird too
strange that it is necessarily evil just
because of that there's nothing stranger
than eating the blood and body of the
Incarnate God you will not find anything
which is more mysterious which is more a
cult which is more esoteric okay and I'm
using those words of course in a way to
help you understand that we can't just
we can't just look at this that an image
and simply because it looks strange to
somehow say that it's evil just because
of that now I'm not defending for
example or call practices some somehow
someone for example like Aleister
Crowley was an obviously evil person and
and for example if you look at
Freemasonry it has been an obvious and
historically you can prove the fact that
Freemasonry has been part of subverting
the west part of the revolutions part of
destroying Christian culture and so I'm
not defending the actions of those
people over there or those organizations
but just because there's an analogy
between certain images within even the
worst occult thing and and let's say
with with Christianity or something that
someone's explaining doesn't make it
evil in itself okay I hope this is
understandable because I'm a bit annoyed
at seeing this happen now I want to give
you a few examples now one of the
examples in this video that I won't talk
about too much the guy shows an image at
Jordan Peterson talks about the image is
an image of folksy and Noah Fuchs he
ánewá
were according to China
mythological tradition were the first
humans so the the first male on the
first female and then they're joining
together represents the beginning of
humanity the beginning of human culture
human tradition and so the guy looks at
this image and he says oh this is the
type of stuff that I saw when I was in
the occult this is the type of stuff
that I saw and look at how the the
characters and so one is holding a
square and the other is holding a
compass and oh my goodness look at how
occult it is because of course the
Freemasons use a square and a compass
and look at how occult it is because the
double snakes the double snakes which go
around this pole are like an elephant
V's Baphomet creature which is has this
double you know snake going up and it's
a cult and it's evil it's like okay you
know yeah fine okay fine I don't want to
defend this image but simply showing
that there's an analogy between this
symbolism Chinese symbolism and what the
Freemasons use and what you know occult
people used in their symbolism doesn't
make this symbolism a point to anything
that's evil it is a totally absurd to
think that let's break it down and we'll
look at this image and see you know what
it is and so first of all we have these
two masculine and feminine characters
that are intertwined and so we have this
notion of the joining of masculine and
feminine as the origin of humanity now
that if a cult people use that type of
symbolism whatever that's fine
Christians also use that type of symptom
Christ is seen as the as the union of
heaven and earth this is normal
symbolism this is something which you
find in the Church Fathers which you
find in the the the symbolism in in
icons in the liturgy that Christ is the
union of heaven and earth that's what
Christ is and so and so the fact that
you reference the union of heaven and
earth doesn't make it evil okay now
let's look at it again they're holding a
square and a compass once again oh this
is evil because Freemasons use a square
and a compass there's nothing evil
about a square and a compass and there's
also nothing evil about a compass
representing heaven and a square
representing earth because we use that
also in our own churches the Orthodox
Church basic architecture is based on a
dome on a square a circle on a square
and so the circle represents heaven and
the square represents earth that is the
same symbolism as as a compass and a
square so that so just and the fact that
the masculine and feminine are united
together this the circle and the square
there's nothing there's nothing there's
nothing evil about that in itself okay
now like I said I'm not saying that
Freemasonry is fine of course we even as
a Orthodox Christian you are not allowed
to be a freemason you're not allowed to
give your loyalty to another secret
organization I'm not saying that any
fast Levy's Baphomet is fine
any fast Levy's Baphomet is is is
obviously part of some strange desire to
impose your will upon the world and in
that kind of Nietzschean sense which is
not the christian sense at all you know
in the christian sense we are meant to
submit our will to the transcendent and
then that will thy will be done right
not not my will okay I mean we can
discuss the subtleties of that at some
other time but what's important to
understand is that the symbolism itself
is not necessarily bad now I'll give
another example I have seen people who
as soon as they see someone who has
their right hand up and their left hand
down you know they'll say oh look it's
the symbolism that really fast levy used
in his before me representation you know
the right hand growing up and the left
hand going down look at how what cult it
is look at how evil it is it's like that
symbolism is also found in Christianity
you can see it in images of the Last
Judgement and you can also see it in
images of the cross itself the Russian
cross has a bar which goes up on one
side and down on the other up on the
right side of Christ and
down on the left side of Christ because
the thief went up the good thief enough
and the bad thief went down and I cross
Oh Lord is like a balance the right
thief went up into heaven and the bad
thief went down into hell it's an image
of the Last Judgment which is inserted
directly into the image of the cross and
so just because you see someone with
their right hand up and their left hand
down doesn't necessarily mean that this
is evil occult symbolism now it could be
evil occult symbolism it depends on how
you're using it it depends on how you're
distorting it it depends on all these
things but to simply show the the visual
relationship between two images is not
enough to to decry a certain amount of
symbolism unless we are able to to look
at things clearly and instead of
attacking people because of how they're
thinking relates to some thinking
historical movement of thinking that's
not enough we need to look at the actual
ideas what is that person saying how are
they using the symbolism that is how we
can identify whether or not these
symbols are used for good or for bad not
simply showing a visual relationship
between the two okay and the same goes
if someone just says oh those ideas are
like the ideas of the Kabbalah and and
the you know with a very dark ominous
tone as if the Kabbalah is you know this
this this immensely evil thing in the
Kabbalah there are things which are
obviously not coherent with Christianity
for example in lurianic kabbalah they're
this notion of the broken vessels and
this idea that that these sparks could
not the vessels could not handle the
divine sparks and this is a very gnostic
way of seeing the world that the world
itself somehow is incapable of receiving
if you will the the divine sparks of God
the will of God are not capable of being
held in these vessels well that of
course is not coherent with Christian
thinking because we we believe that God
is good but just because certain rabbi a
certain Kabbalistic rabbi
made an analogy in scripture you know
doesn't mean that that analogy is
necessarily bad sometimes there can be
an insight there that's worth looking at
like I said we need to look at the ideas
themselves the application of this
symbolism and not just look at the
accidental historical or visual
relationship between different images
that is not enough and so I just want to
say to a lot of those people that have
been attacking during Peterson you're
not you're doing yourself a disservice
especially those of you that are
traditionally Christian because if you
look at an image for example of two
intertwining snakes and these two snakes
with the heads looking at each other and
you say ooh that's evil
that's a cult that you know look at look
at how evil that is I will like to
remind you that our bishops use that
symbolism in their staff and their staff
have two snakes which come up which come
up head to head at the top and so to
simply point to that symbol and say that
it's evil because because some some 19th
century a co person used it is not
enough okay you need to understand what
it's referring to and need to be able to
discern whether or not this is good
whether or not this is bad all right
guys
and so sorry about the the rant and I
hope despite the fact that I was being
very Randy in this video that it was
useful to you and maybe I'll come back
on this at another time in a in a calmer
more dissected way but but if you feel
that I if you're wondering what I'm
talking about and if you're curious you
know if you still think that some I'm
supporting the occult go ahead and write
it down in the comments hopefully I'll
try to be more involved in and try to
answer your comments and see see where
we can go with that so thanks a lot if
you enjoy the symbolic world content
there's a lot of things you can do to
help us out if you're not subscribe
please do go ahead and share this to all
your friends if you can get involved in
the discussion we have a Facebook group
in which people can talk about these
subjects I will put all those links in
the description and also if you can
please support us financially by going
to my website
come slash support and I also have a
patreon and a subscribe star so thanks
again and I will see you soon